[Music]
and what did you just say
pull up baby enemies I don't understand
good bye bye submitted by Christian from
Texas a Christian or Christian a federal
lawsuit was filed over a video of an
officer handcuffing a crying
third-grader oh man please don't tell me
the third grader was caught son at crack
eight years old did you see the third
grader selling crack yes pocket contents
enhance enhance enhance enhance enhance
enhance enhance enhance enhance enhance
yeah 89 and throwing up pretty fast
please stop selling drugs third-grader
it's probably like us some on third
grader he's like instead of ethology
I just want my mama Oh got a mustache
kid relax my friend I brought like a
Rambo knife to show-and-tell for school
when you got a big trouble oh wow really
yeah real one-handed damn I mean he
doesn't know like he just thought it was
cool but the teacher freaked out it made
a big ordeal about it yeah definitely
you don't tell people I don't remember
my teacher self ever telling me you
can't bring certain items to show until
you can't bring a gun to school
Yeah right yeah I guess they thought I
was pretty obvious yeah you're good well
this is a condom and that's my story
first Joey he always used to itch his
balls like when he sat cross-legged like
this and then he put his hat like
through his pants those nice boy was
funny in elementary school you guys you
always remember somebody for something
that they did yeah yeah I don't know her
their names exactly by I remembered
there was bra hotdog boy boy AIDS boy
yeah a boy is actually her half-brother
who stepbrother yes that brother who
actually I remember from the bus stop
because he wouldn't shared drinks with
his friends before you guys so this is
before Dave and I met it turns out small
world David went to middle school middle
school with my step-brother oh I didn't
know yeah so when my stepbrothers like
hey cuz this is when your Alex from UCLA
whatever girl video window
my separate is like a what school that
guy and David and damn it's like you
your wolf sister like yeah I do what's
up and then this is really a picture I
was like oh that's aids boy
because we all knew him as a boy because
of the bus not everybody remembers this
conversation where he wouldn't share his
Fruitopia with anybody because he
thought he would get AIDS drink so he
would I don't think so that's all you
twist the top off no I just tastes like
sugar and death and so they just and
then I just one guy remember here like
what if I guess waterfall he does not
still get aids from it well I started
cracking up this was aids boy man my
brother will I love you don't make fun
of me oh yeah my bad dude I knew his
aids boy everything was good actually
yeah yeah well anyways to this story how
you get it yeah so wonderful when you
all thought it goes up back up to we go
yeah that was this video that went viral
back in 2015 but it took place in 2014
and so what happened before this video
starts is that this eight year old boy
and this nine year old girl both have
ADHD they're both being really rowdy
they were swinging at a teacher and so a
cop showed up at the school and then
ended up arresting him so now I'll show
you guys the video Oh what the hell
happened today what's here not arresting
him handcuffing up okay like just a
scare you know just like we're doing
I'll Drive human [ __ ] well in the video
the cop is saying that the kid was
swinging at him and so I guess he's
grabbed his wrists yeah so here we go
what are you trying to punch the police
officer bad boy portioning the child
above the elbow
[Music]
look at item shoulders that fool thinks
he's an Incredible Hulk he's trying to
break the cuffs right now I got so sad
oh my god dammit cuz I immediately think
of do you want to abuse the police
officers after this we mean abuse did
you want to put handcuffs on the cops
and make them go like this make them how
would you like it maybe for you though
because you're also thinking about your
kids temperament yeah you know it means
so you don't you're not a parent of that
kid so you don't know his behavior type
either because as a kid I was a third
grader at his age I [ __ ] stabbed the
kid so you got a fever I realized like I
literally took a pen like this I went to
a kid I don't went [ __ ] right through
his cheek through his mouth yeah I know
I'm being bites cuz immediately I think
of my own so anyway this ended up being
a federal lawsuit filed by the ACLU the
American Civil Liberties Union and so
they were saying that they this was
unconstitutional that they violated the
kid's constitutional rights and so
recently so since it took place back in
2014 now recently the judge has ruled
that yes it was unconstitutional and the
fact that like the reason there's no
policies that say that you should ever
handcuff a kid above the elbows ever
we're supposed to do it on the wrist
it's like a normal person well here's
the thing I didn't know kids have
constitutional rights constitutional
rights
I always raised a different way yeah if
you compare this to like a Asian school
this is [ __ ] nothing dude yep yeah
but they have you kneeling on rice
grains and [ __ ] the super sweet to him
you know you mean yeah my dad spoke to
me that way I know but he just beat me
while handcuffing me
this is just more like well you know you
learn your lesson this is what's gonna
happen to you maybe you shouldn't have
done on the elbows maybe a little bit
lower but I can understand this as like
a scare yeah it seems like he was trying
to teach him about the law exactly
that's what it seemed like to me kids
like one of those [ __ ] kids like I'm
talking like ends up on dr. Phil [ __ ]
kids you know I mean like swinging yeah
yeah so I understand why piers we mad
because you look at both sides yeah I
get both sides but at the other hand
this is this is pretty easy if he
handcuffed his ankles somehow if you
were swinging around yeah then you
basically you know that uh canine arm
thing what's the key no no no were they
like have the dark imma bite the arm
[Laughter]
it's like a big wing monster what about
what about for you I'll ask Bart first
let's say tyka is eight years old yeah
and then the officer or whatever they're
like well your kid was acting up and he
swing and he swung on the officer so
they handcuffed him a little how would
you feel would you be like what the [ __ ]
why did you do that to my kid I'd be
like what the [ __ ] mild escape if Tyco
was exactly like me when I was eight
then I think that would have been
perfect behavior because I've been
arrested I ever since I was a kid like
all the up until I was old because I
just got a lot of been arrested it was
much more violent than that and the cop
is yelling and he's usually cursing even
when I was a kid so to that lack
actually to me looks like police
protocol but we find out that above the
elbows actually is it so I guess for me
I'd be like well what what is the
constitutional way to apprehend a kid
because it does come to that sometimes
and for me like know if if I was the
eight-year-old kid I'm gonna be running
around and doing crazy [ __ ] and throwing
things and so like I have to be
handcuffed or handcuffed to a chair or
something like that so if tyka is the
exact same way then to me I would have
no problem with that I want to know what
the public would say if they were to
release a video of his kid five minutes
of prior swinging at the car
you're just looking just like punching
everyone flipping over starting fires I
want it I bet people be like he deserves
it yes yeah I said a chiropractic place
on fire when I was like 6 you know so
like you [ __ ] monster was like please
please put the kid somewhere there's a
burny girls down well uh so I saw two
officers in that video right so I'd be
like okay
I as a mom I'm with you like I'd be like
don't [ __ ] touch my kid I know he's a
piece of [ __ ] like I understand my kids
piece of [ __ ] that's my fault
and I would I sympathize with my child
cuz he's mine right so I'm like don't do
anything like [ __ ] call me out I'll
come over there's two cops like let them
just be like well you're not you're not
leaving like let him do his [ __ ] in the
corner and have his little [ __ ]
tactual just don't touch my [ __ ] kid
I think that's that's impossible because
if you're doing this if the cop doesn't
touch the kid the kid's gonna touch the
cop so the kid's gonna run through the
kids legs the kids gonna come yeah but
those are some big ass men you know the
but he has to touch him yeah if you
don't want contact like what instead of
like just voicing problems what's the
solution to it cuz all I'm hearing is
like don't do this but okay if you don't
do this then how do you touch the kid
well you get a bunch of pillows and
stuffed animals and then you just kind
of pop them back so that's the
constitutional way and it's comfy it's
just like it's cushion like oh it was
Amelia about like HAMP them touching him
it's more like the fact that it's like
look how how uncomfortable that is like
you're clearly trying to inflict pain on
the handcuffs aren't designed to be
luxurious
yeah handcuffs are meant to be
uncomfortable as [ __ ] and if you've ever
been zip tied I've been zip tie to
[ __ ] like that [ __ ] hurts like a
mother been in the back of a police car
it's all hard plastic this too by the
way it's like this none of those things
was designed
by Mercedes or have German engineering
or made out of silk like all I should is
meant to be uncomfortable so like that
being like this I'm like yeah of course
it's supposed to be like that well what
if what if it's the it's because the
handcuffs gave too much gift so that if
they were handcuffed normally he'd still
be like this you know yeah that's why
they had to put it look at an intent and
it didn't look like the cop was trying
to hurt him it looks like he just made a
very poor choice in how to restrain the
child and he didn't understand maybe the
comfortability level but I don't think
as a cop he singing about I'm trying to
make this troublemaker comfortable is I
gotta restrain them let them calm down
first and if you follow the rules I can
take this off and I like the way it was
talking to him he was doing that I
remember when I was like 13 I got caught
for doing graffiti and then when I was
at the police station the cop was like
take off your earrings and I was like I
couldn't take them all off because one
of them was like I had an infection it
was like hurting me and then I can't
take this one off officer and he's like
take it off I'm gonna take it off for
you
and I was like taking it off like trying
my hardest I'm like you're so sadistic
you're enjoying this aren't you and all
super touch like client oh he's not like
an SMM clients like Oh like dramatic
about it too like oh you've all you pigs
you guys are so sadistic you're enjoying
this aren't you the funny thing is I
mean like when your kid you're super
dramatic right so in my mind I'm not in
trouble I'm not wrong for doing graffiti
and getting caught for it I'm wrong I
think the cop is wrong for making you
want to take off my earrings that's all
I could think about [ __ ] you cop you're
fired you joined us you [ __ ] bullies
brutality [ __ ]
here you go there's blood coming up just
like as a cop you enjoy Civil Rights
Division of the US Department of Justice
got involved in this case and they were
even suggesting that the court consider
whether the handcuffing was putative rat
necessary to ensure safety so then
they're just saying like you know the
the officer didn't have to go to that
extent of handcuffing above the elbow
that's just the whole drive and so
because of that yeah so because now like
the federal judge did rule it was
unconstitutional Ike if his argument is
like oh it's cuz his wrists don't fit
handcuff one pack of his bicep
Hank up the other one to the chair look
I think you know sport judge yeah I
don't like had mal-intent he goes well
I'm a cuffing this way because it's
gonna hurt him yeah didn't seem like
that was like it seemed like that at all
it's guilty by stupidity that conclusion
David it's because the kid was seeing
like how it hurts it's a [ __ ] matter I
said that [ __ ] all the time when it
didn't exaggerate all the time I'm just
trying to give you guys the voice of
what the they were saying in court so
what was the consequences are based on
what you know saying I cannot see what
it did do above elbows because you know
I understand that has to probably come
out here so they can come out here the
kids can usually just go like this now
and now it's a lot of them and now
they're gonna go back to swinging at the
cops the real question is how come
people can't calm their kids down
without [ __ ] using force dude I
remember I guess I answer that question
I remember one time we were eating in
k-town TIFF was with Isaac and we're all
sitting down and then TIFF was like as
it can you please stop him very calmly
very nicely and then Isaac goes no mommy
don't hit me
what a little boy and then people were
just looking at that home though after
that yeah dude I'm like I should hit you
holy crap I don't know dramatic she was
like Isaac can you please stop doing it
and I was just like no I didn't know you
I would have been like oh my god let's
call somebody like I don't even know
what I would do my kid that I was
laughing who did that recently to me
[ __ ] Vanessa when we were driving my
pet South Pasadena I know she's like
[ __ ] was done and I was like that's the
high school right there yeah jackass
hope you guys enjoyed that episode of JK
news make sure to stay connected because
we're constantly updating our social
media so follow us at JK films for
Instagram and at JK films for Twitter to
watch more videos click right over here
[Music]